5:27 in the morning
time to go get this work to get
everything laid out since football
football I'm ready
103 California time there's no rankings
right now there's no we think you're
better than him we're here to discover
that so the first six hours of any
finals is probably the most fascinating
six hours we hear it we say it we
believe it but can we see the effect
the games online you can see in a
person's eyes it's noticeable the effect
they make the players around them better
the effector welcome to the in factory
welcome welcome
I mean it's gonna drink something that
I've been looking forward to since
really young you know them watching all
the stuff for a long time and listening
to the guys they're like yeah it's just
something to never forget
so I support Jameis Winston from the
Tampa Bay Buccaneers and congrats man
y'all finally made it to lead 11 final
embrace the grind and just get after and
enjoy it every day you can give this
opportunity when it comes one so live it
up you know it's a competition but at
the end of the day you know it's a
family a lot of times that you will live
you end up seeing the NFL and played
against in college one day just like me
not many kids have this opportunity and
you're select group that got it so make
sure you go out there take full
advantage of it have a blast and tear it
up
this bill will be different here for me
in LA you know getting to meet these
West Coast kids this is honestly the
second time I've ever been out here just
different from where I live where I grew
up I like to hunt fish Louisiana duck on
day one says got here fishing you know
transportation y'all living if you're
not competing well brother just called
himself with your pants we're for
fishing yeah it's me my brothers were
competing with each other see he's gonna
catch too much to us that day come on
Suchi yeah he gonna fat mouth huh guys
I'm gonna caught one fish he's got eight
I guess you saw I'm worried and always
trying to have that edge and always
trying to be like that
it's always been a dream to get you so I
mean
I've been watching the unit 11 since I
was nine years old and being able to
kind of watch it you know try to dream
it and now live the dream is just
amazing we bring the top 24 quarterbacks
in the country after evaluating over a
thousand by the 11 staff to Los Angeles
to compete against one another for a
spot at the opening on Nikes campus it's
the deepest group of pastors we've had I
don't want to say quarterback says
that's yet to be seen
definitely adrenaline rush knowing that
you're gonna be competing against the
top quarterbacks in the country it's
about to get real real soon
dreams come true it is why I need to be
19 to work work work until I need a
situation where I can be a part of the
leader live
anxious to go out there and compete and
just see how I compare to everyone
people say I'm the lowest-ranked guy
here I can care less about stories and
all that kind of stuff
come into the elite 11 I expect it to be
a great group of guys who can all rip it
you
I've been preparing for this moment
since I was in sixth grade so I mean
even joins experience right now which
way where it says student
start to discover deep learning and
greatness at the edge of
uncomfortableness so Jake he thinks he's
gonna be coming down and having to sit
down with us they asking all these
questions trying to make him
uncomfortable and he walked into the
door and there's his mom a bay area
broadcaster everybody knows they say
there are three sides to every story
yours theirs and the truth
hello um it's good is it good that's
weird
all right have a seat I wasn't expecting
that it's pretty cool it is cool we've
never been in this situation before I
know were you surprised when you saw me
yes this is your taste of the elite 11
so far the first day how's it going what
would be more uncomfortable in the first
true official interview with your mom
how would you describe your personality
as a quarterback and just like he does
as a passer he's pure I'm very
determined um cool calm and collective
those are words that describing a
quarterback what is the thing you love
most about your mother
ah my mother my she's tough she's smart
she's giving me an interview writer I
love all this this is good this is good
stuff it is just tape so surreal
experience cuz I seen her do interviews
on with her job so I mean there's an eye
opening thank you we hug all right
okay good luck there awesome so proud of
you cool this is awesome okay go get
them all right all right you must learn
how to thrive being uncomfortable she
have a book set up with your name when
all 24 get in the same room and they
started looking on going oh that's the
guy from New Jersey I've heard about
he's a sleeper and oh that's to do from
Texas did you hear about his season they
really kind of find their internal ring
and they need us to kind of explain
didn't listen you're coming in on a
clean slate these three days they are
serious they are intense you're gonna
get pushing a challenge but all of you
have some unique trait you have
something special about you
it's called the it factor so welcome to
the it factory you reveal your it factor
when you walk into a room and everybody
knows you're in that room to make them
look when it clicks that my single
purpose is a human being playing this
position is to make everybody else
around me better that's when you reach
your dreams you all want to play in the
NFL take it from a broken-down old man
that did it for 14 years it's the
hardest thing you'll ever do the only
way you make it is if you love it more
than what a brain ship and we're about
to find that out and now go get your
asses on the bus
he's gonna catch that thing turn and
he's gone this is what you take from the
elite 11 that's what makes it real
perfect
a lot of good here dude she's the best
password I've seen there's a lot of good
the majority of the game is mental so we
have to have dr. Mike Gervais the
world's leader in high-performance
psychology so you take all this complex
information we get it down to one breath
one igniter he gets it cuz he's in the
football community and has been for a
long time Pete Carroll's when the
greatest coaches ever you know trust him
with his football team so why wouldn't I
trust it with a group of teenage boys
you always talk about having a vision
believing it keep your mind calm and
chaotic situations and I've always been
you know told no a lot in my life but
you know ultimately I believe in my
vision and I made my vision come true
that comes from belief you know in
yourself and and that belief is what
makes you Brazilian you can't find your
best until you go against the best you
want to call it out so j300 little
weight lose there's a mouthful though
tough lip gun don't write but they still
it's the Fox too high that's what killed
me listen that's just the extension
through getting everything here right so
whether it goes are not it's about
getting you right right now it's just
this comic I've ever seen in my life at
first I was like what is what is he
talking about and then the more I
started listening than the more I
started getting engaged I was like okay
this dude's up to something
listen it's one breath one thought it
feels forced right now but over time
that'll be a mechanism for you that'll
be really clean and I started getting a
pot of the thoughts in my head and you
really him tough left 308 quick why hi
hi
this group is hungry to learn they've
got a high IQ there there's a noticeable
intelligence and their hunger to want to
train their mind it's it's a parent say
I'm approaching situation with a whole
new mana see we have people that are
best-in-class in what they do pour into
these young men and if they just get 1%
that 1% almost makes that kid a hundred
percent better so if there is an it
factor it would begin with being present
and that is trainable a lot of nuggets
today is a good start
you're one step closer to being a
quarterback big bucks
when you were in the heisman next year
you better point to this moment this is
a transformational moment Jake I put my
money on you dude walk off you did not
disappoint my man